chanel miller was once known only as
emily doe the anonymous victim of a
sexual assault by a swimmer at stanford
university
then last year she decided to step into
the public eye with a memoir pointedly
called
know my name it went on to become a new
york times best seller and now
she's making her way as a young artist
living right here in new york city
we caught up with her to find out how
her life has changed
[Music]
you move to new york city in the middle
of a pandemic
what has that been like for you i'm very
familiar with the trees
in my neighborhood i've you know
developed deep grooves in the sidewalks
from walking the same loops
but when i was writing the book i was
alone at home for
three years without any co-workers and
without anyone knowing that i was at
home
so i felt like okay i've been here
before
but the difference for me now is that
i'm not as mentally isolated
because this time people are aware of
who i am and what i'm doing
and i also think i was forced to live
in a suspended state of uncertainty
for a really long time i waited a year
and a half to get that verdict and i had
to just keep reassuring myself that no
matter
the outcome i would figure out a way to
be okay and right now that's something
we're all learning
how to do and i hope that people don't
us underestimate that
as a skill it's been nearly a year since
you revealed your identity
what's it like now that the entire world
knows your name
i'm really grateful that before
lockdown happened i was able to have a
few book signings
and finally meet people face to face and
experience
that warmth directly
you know people would line up and write
their names on post-it notes in the book
so that i could sign them and i've kept
every single one because i'm meeting the
people who
have saved me you know when you were
growing up it was hard to find
representation
which made it hard for you to identify
with your asian heritage
talk to me a little bit more about that
yeah i mean growing up
i didn't see people who looked like me
on prominent
screens and even before i started doing
interviews last year
i kept questioning if i truly belonged
in these prominent
seats um but then i thought maybe it's
because i'm not used to seeing
people like me sitting there and so
that's why it feels so unnatural so if i
do it
maybe it'll become more natural for
someone else who
looks like me in the wake of the
coronavirus there have been
there's been an uptick in attacks on
asians but specifically in this country
on asian americans
have you experienced any of that well
first i want to say
that it's important to note that it's
not new
it's more physical and frequent and
aggressive
but it's not new and if you speak to any
asian american they can list
out microaggressions they've experienced
since
childhood and insulting racist comments
we can't tolerate this anymore
especially now
when the hate crimes are getting more
violent and pervasive we're not going to
sit back
you're right that your art is
what helped you get through some of the
darkest periods of your life and now
you are creating art and exhibiting art
what does that feel like i think a lot
about how
when i was in court it's a place that's
completely devoid of
art and that was difficult for me
you know art has immense power to
nourish people and to also address your
humanity saying yeah just to give
someone something nice to look at
so that was important to me and now
what's incredible is that the asian art
museum
has given me a 75 foot
wall that's amazing yeah and it's
something
that i never would have asked for or
thought to ask for
say hey can i fill that wall so the fact
that they
brought me to the museum stood me on the
street before this
massive wall and said this is yours
again that's restructuring how i see
myself
and also telling me how much space i
deserve to
take up in the world and that's what i
hope people feel when they go there and
see it
wow anthony michelle the mural that she
has created uh is called i was i am i
will be
and during that victim impact statement
that she read in court she talked about
being with everybody being with little
girls being with people
who are not believe she was with them
and you heard her say to me that now
it's come full circle
that the folks around her who have come
to see her who have come
and have read her book she is supported
by them
survivors voices are so important to
hear
and it's so good to hear hers i love her
story i love the whole conversation but
i love her story about keeping the
post-it notes that were attached to the
books that she signed
because because she the connection with
every one of them meant something to her
we both odd when we heard